hey guys happy holidays it wouldn't be a
holiday without a holiday makeup
tutorial by yours truly
now this is gonna be a very special look
this is gonna be something that you can
wear to whatever it is that you
celebrate if you don't celebrate
Christmas you can wear this I don't know
tweak your grave all right we're gonna
start off because I don't actually have
any makeup on right now so we're gonna
do like a quick little something I'm
gonna paint on some stuff on the face so
old we will guys look at this hair like
look like a key if I tried to do this I
couldn't do it oh boy I haven't seen
breakouts here morning sip probably the
only serious thing that I'm going to
mention in this video is my obsession
with Arcana marcona I'm having some bad
breakouts I actually do use these little
pads and they clear up everything okay
now back to being a jackass
to start off this look hold on it's my
favorite moisturizer it's also Arcana
Arcona well pulled a lot of roll quick
roll my god like Oceanos gonna come down
the chimney he's gonna see me looking so
beautiful that he's gonna give me all
the presents that I want I'm gonna say
Santa would you bring me baby a Santa
Baby puddin its buxom debauchery all
three and it started yet I want to be
real tan today so I'll put a law on this
bronzer a little of this foundation fall
on the law foundation alright just get
her a nice and even it looks like
someone crapped on my face if that's
something that you're into that's weird
have your cell phone
poopy little Christmas someone just shat
on my face
kind of so tan I'm so tan I'm like
bronze ready for the beach it's like hey
Barbie a little bit of powder it's
basically like you're baking a cake and
you're putting on icing or a painting a
building you're painting the side of a
building imagine the building is your
face you put your first layer of paint
on you put the powder on to just
instantly dry the first layer of paint
did you have applied to your wall a
little extra powder under my eyes so
that what I'm doing my eye makeup I'll
just be able to go first like that all
the excess fall away will just go away
now I went to the drugstore to buy some
drugs and makeup at a hard time finding
any red type of eyeshadow a lot of the
places were like no one was aware that I
want to wear it it's red enough
obviously your we're going to need some
green red and green happy freaking
holidays I hope you powder all over
my face but it's green kids don't ever
use your teeth to open up things it's
bad my mom tells me I'm a dentist
my dentist all right
[Music]
it looks kind of good not over going for
here
it looks too good this gold is so sick
oh my gosh like the three wise men
brought their gold and myrrh to the
manger and said I don't know what they
said
falala lalala look I went to Catholic
school I should know these things
I don't so amazed by this stuff I'm
gonna go and get more of colors that I
will wear on a daily basis let's just
really get in there nobody up at the
green this we're gonna use the brows
[Music]
it's not a big stick firm ellipse this
looks cool too we need to pick up the
speed now we're gonna do a little liner
some green liner here under the eye cool
fabulous we're gonna do a black liner
[Music]
okay we need some blush can I use a
little highlighter first because this is
a look needs to be I like it I think I
might want to do darker because that
will do
bronzer he'll shoot I've already
screwing it up no no no no do a little
bronzing here I really want to do some
contouring follow Allah Allah honestly
cuz Kim Kardashian is the contour Queen
it's like is that what does your face
look like without all of that art doing
I am Kim Kardashian contour the crap out
of this you're not gonna be able to
recognize me so if you're going to a
parade this is definitely the look for
you you're going to do boyfriends for
dinner Christmas holiday dinner
definitely wear this because you will
make a statement actually only wear this
if you plan on trying to get him to
break up with you
what hotbar look emaciated I'll contour
my nose cuz my nose is too big and we
can fix it with makeup highlight look
out of it oh my god I'm so shining I'm
so shimmering I'm a queen if any of you
guys remember brief from escape routes
this is actually her makeup line and
it's pretty sweet it's alchemy and it's
all natural now only use some lashes and
we're set
no emotions that always that lashes
alright
these are actually pretty nice lashes
[Music]
can blend this in a little bit this is
really fun I had a really great time so
here's my finished I don't know what to
call it I'm not sure let me know what
you guys think I should call this look I
call it a hot freakin holiday fiesta
fruitcake and mix that's all of that for
you guys today I hope you guys have an
awesome holiday and awesome Christmas
and a great new year whatever it is that
you celebrate I hope that you were
enjoying it I'm gonna go and shower my
face off now
[Music]
[Applause]